finally at 4 30 for those of you who  frequently eat burritos check it out you  know when everything spills out  everywhere well take a look at this some  very clever engineering students at john  hopkins came up with what they call the  perfect solution tasty tape  essentially edible tape that you can  stick  to food  yes it's true i know ted can't believe  it but they aren't revealing their  secret formula yet because they are in  the process of obtaining a patent but it  is totally edible  but do you think this is necessary  christian i don't know i mean i think if  you just fold it right i think it works  but i'm really curious to see what the  tape will taste like like nothing i'm  sure it doesn't matter says ted  is it the answer to i guess a messy  burrito this must be not just burritos  an issue for many people for everything  ted says the five o'clock is coming  right up